first thing I'd like to do is set some
expectations what's going to happen here
I'd have to add this in I hadn't thought
about with cryptocurrency we won't be
talking about cryptocurrency what I hope
to give you is a working understanding
of some of the terms the common terms
used and the key drivers for choosing
cryptography methodologies algorithms
and strengths so you won't leave here
being an expert hopefully you'll leave
here with enough information to make
intelligent decisions about what you're
doing with cryptography so the first
thing we should go over is what is
cryptography and if you're like me the
first thing that you do is you go look
at Wikipedia and Wikipedia has this
moderate moderately well-defined
definition it's the practice and study
of techniques to secure communications
and the presence of third parties called
adversaries and what I like to focus on
is the fact that we're securing
communications and that there are
adversaries right you don't have to
study it
unless you're a cryptographer you don't
need to study cryptography but it's
important to understand that what you're
trying to do is you're trying to secure
communication even that even if that's
just communication with yourself storing
on a hard drives taking in memory across
the network to yourself it's still
communicating and it's there are
adversaries that will try and get it so
how cryptography works the first thing
to understand that cryptography all
starts with secrets
so secrets are an essential part of
practical cryptography you can have
cryptography without secrets it's just
not a very good idea but secret has been
in use for more than cryptography as
well right there's very old stories
about using pass phrases to gain
entrance to things pop a very famous one
is the Open Sesame to be able to gain
access and that was a secret right in
the United States during Prohibition
times the place is called speakeasies
where you could actually go consume
alcohol because you couldn't anywhere
else and you would have to have a proper
passphrase to know that they weren't
going to you weren't an official trying
to arrest them
in ancient cryptography they used
methods the cryptography methods were
secret
and so you would have to know the method
but that was the secret part all right
how you would actually go from the
plaintext to the cipher tax from the
ciphertext back to the plaintext that
was the secret in modern cryptography
the methodologies are well known they're
documented they are peer-reviewed they
go through this large process to be
accepted and they're published in
academic journals and oftentimes they're
turned into if they succeed and they're
accepted they turn into distributable
libraries in PHP we have M crypt open
SSL and sodium and there are others so
secrets that in modern cryptography is
done in the form of keys and those are
what we we use to add to an algorithm to
turn plaintext in the ciphertext and
back the other way
generating and exchanging keys though
can be a tricky business before the
mid-70s 1970's passing secrets was a
thing that people did with briefcases
and handcuffs and long trips as he would
have someone with the secret with the
codes in in World War two
it was code books you would have to just
pass around these large you had to pass
around secrets so that both of you knew
what the secret was for today or the
secret was for this time or the secret
was for this message so in modern
cryptography to make that usable and
affordable and accessible probably the
most critical advance would be key
exchange so some of you are familiar
with diffie-hellman key exchange and
what diffie-hellman key exchange is is
the ability for two people to have a
secret value to be able to come up with
a known common value but never pass the
value across the wire so when you make a
connection to a web server that uses
TLS often fir - as ssl this is what's
going on in the background all right
this is the diffie-hellman key exchange
and it's a process I won't get all into
it you can read about it that's actually
a picture from Wikipedia so there's
really good information on Wikipedia on
how that actually works I've also got
some references to some books that go
through it really well - but it's a it's
a it's a way to actually come up with a
common secret from your own secrets
never pass them around you can both
communicate in a secure manner and to do
this is very expensive it's it's using
prime numbers very large prime numbers
and modular arithmetic so it's kind of
this black box of magic that happens
which isn't so important for us to
understand today just understand that
it's this is what happens and you're
exchanging a key and key exchange is a
really big important thing if you've
ever had to converse with a with a third
party like if you use Amazon or if you
use github you're communicating over TLS
pssh using SSH key you have to keep yet
to move that thing back and forth that
key which can make it difficult key
exchange makes it so that you don't have
to do that
the next super awesome piece of voodoo
mathematics that came about was
public/private key pairs and this is so
you don't have to exchange secrets so
much like key exchange the
diffie-hellman key exchange says I have
a secret do you have a secret we're
going to create a combined secret public
private key cryptography says that I
have a secret I'll give you just enough
to do it you have to do on your side and
then you'll give me your a public key
which has just enough information to do
the same the most famous one of this is
called RSA named after the three
inventors of the product of the process
also before they invented this there's
actually a British mathematician that
came up with it basically design the
same thing before they did but it was
super secret because it was part of
British intelligence so he was not
allowed to tell anybody for a very long
time but
symmetric key cryptography which is what
the public/private key pair is talked
about made it say she didn't have to do
that key exchange so it made a lot
easier to move data without having to do
this complicated process of doing key
exchange and building that in the other
part of cryptography is ciphers so keys
and ciphers so we see some ancient
ciphers here on the left that's just
basically our placement on the top right
is that is rot13 I believe know what is
it rot 3 yes very very simple but that
used to be considered acceptable
cryptography 20 years ago and in the
bottom that's RSA so modern cryptography
ciphers use mathematics very complicated
mathematics and we'll get into that a
bit more later
just to understand that it's all math
it's why you need computers to do it
it's because it's all mathematics there
are different ways that cryptography is
used and we'll go over that as well
so the important things that we'll talk
about that are happen in a daily life of
a developer someone who is writing
applications are going to be encryption
digital signatures key derivation and
hashing and key derivation is what a lot
of people call password hashing even in
PHP libraries we call it password
hashing it is hashing but it's a process
of doing multiple hashes in different
methodologies for generating keys so
they call it key duration so encryption
encryption is used to place data in a
form that can be reconstituted into its
original form so what it can be
encrypted can also be decrypted it comes
in two flavors symmetric which is a
shared key and a symmetric which is
public key encryption so an asymmetric
encryption you have a shared secret I'm
sorry yes an asymmetric encryption you
do not
have a shared secret that's symmetric
encryption asymmetric encryption have
your own set of keys and they're
different and what you're going to do is
you're going to use a public key to
encrypt data for a private key and
digital signatures go the other way
around
I'll get more in depth than that in just
a moment symmetric encryption is where
you share a same secret the same key
same Keys used to encrypt it is to
decrypt hashing is where you create a
representation of the value and it
cannot be reversed it's reproducible if
it's a proper hash but it cannot be
reversed so when you have something it
doesn't normally have enough information
to regenerate it on this particular
input the input is smaller than the hash
but more often if you see when you're
downloading a file and you see that it
has an md5 or sha-1 representation and
there's not enough information to
recreate it but the function allows you
to come up with a string of the same
length every single time and the
difference between a good input hash and
a bad one is how well how how well it
prevents collision what you don't want
is you don't want two things having the
same hash it will happen because just
the way to algorithms work you're just
going to have that so the larger your
hash the better the algorithm the less
likely you are to be able to create that
we'll get into that more also and a
modern hashing algorithm won't create an
input role credit collision for an input
whose size is equal to or less than the
value of the hash so because it's the
same size you can't have a collision
it's only one it's larger so if you have
a 30 character string and you're doing a
48 character hash you never have to be
concerned about collisions because they
just can't happen on a proper algorithm
so in our example our input size is less
than our output size it means it would
be impossible to create another hash but
if you have a larger value like this
image it's condensing it down
and there's a popular attack it's been
recent called shattered say one hurt or
shattered all right we do have crypto
geeks
okay so shattered is it is possible
using a PDF to adjust the headers in the
PDF and so you can have a different
document with the same hash so you're
taking something I just not necessary
the same size and you're you're
condensing it down to the point where
you can keep adjusting the headers you
you would change the what the document
is and oftentimes that is I agree to do
something or the terms of a document so
if you sign a document if you sign a PDF
and you hash that that should be secure
except if you're depending on what
you're hashing it with and shattered is
for a sha-1 which is an older hash you
can create the new document that you
want to interpret as being signed make
it brute and do brute force you make a
hash does it match no change the headers
does it match now no change the header
does it match now it's possible albeit
expensive so in order to do that I did
the math on AWS and before discounts it
would cost about $10,000 in GPU rental
on AWS and it would take a week so it's
a lot of these things mean when you hear
about things that are possible to do
it's it's it's getting easier now that
anyone can go rent ten thousand GPUs but
it's still prohibitive and there are
also ways around that you can use a shot
too and use another hash as well an md5
so if you hatch it twice using two
different algorithms and you have two
different values it's nearly impossible
to find one not impossible but nearly
impossible to find one that you could be
able to create both with that would take
a lot more time hashes although
fantastic by themselves aren't terribly
useful because all the hash tells you is
that that is this that is the data that
you have you got so if I download a file
and the hash match is fantastic that's
the that's the actual data that was
there but who's too
that the hash didn't change with the
data so on an attacker uploaded a new
file that has malware in it and then
generated a new hash it's perfectly safe
law download it I'll verify the hash the
data is good so what you want at that
point is digital signatures digital
signatures are hash mixed with a key
with a function that uses a key so it's
not like you would just stick the key on
take the hash off and so that's going to
verify the integrity of data as well as
the fact that the individual that you
are assuming created that the data did
create the data and so a digital
signature looks very simple like a hash
so these are hm X and it follows the
same thing and there are some rules that
have to be required for an HTML and that
is that if you have the same data with
the same key you get the same signature
every single time that's kind of a
requirement if you have the same data
with a different key you get a different
signature because that's to prevent
someone from being able to say here's
the data you got from person a but
person B signed it and if you also if
you have different data it would be
different as well so it's very similar
to hashing although it's putting that
key in there that secret value that no
one else should be able to know that can
tell you that I'm signing it and as it's
me as an individual signing it so if you
are if you sign your github commits
which I have to you're doing this you're
saying that I as an individual signed
this and you can trust that this commit
was made by me not because it just has
my email and my name on there because
anybody can put that in but because I
have been I have provided github with my
public key and it can verify the
signature that I made with my private
key against the data key duration is
another really good use of hashing
functions so key derivations are
cyclical hashes where the hash is fed
into the algorithm over
over again to generate a brand new hash
it's done many times to require a lot of
computing power the idea behind it is to
in require a lot of computing power
hashes should be very fast if I need to
verify data I should be able do that
very quickly the faster the better
however for passwords I don't want you
to be able to try them constantly over
over over again I want it to be very
difficult for you to be able to
brute-force a password so key derivation
by by design is very computationally
expensive and it also uses in good
methodologies for key derivation they
use random values called salts and the
salts are used as well over and over
again to create this different value and
I'll show you a very oversimplified
value or oversimplified example of why
that's necessary so I hate passwords is
actually one of the top passwords in use
today mixed with a random salt get you a
random value the hashed value you take
the hashed value in the salt you get
another value and you do it again and
again and again and so that's how you're
generating you're basically going over
over again to make it computationally
expensive which is important because the
way that passwords work is you're trying
to give your users time to change them
one of the nice things about passwords
as opposed to biometrics is you can
change them it's important to secure
these things in such a matter to buy
your users time so if your site gets
attacked and you may just have a simple
blog site and you and many people think
well I just have a simple blog site what
do I care
unfortunately your users probably use
their email as the username and they
probably use the same password for their
email that they did on your blog
most people don't know better and that's
what they do
and if I can hack your site and get
their password and I have their email
and then I can get their their email
account I can now do password resets on
every other thing that I want to have
access to those because those are always
sent to email so I can get their bank
account I can get their credit cards I
can get enough information from their I
can get on to their their shared drives
where they probably have their tax
statements that have person identifiable
information and enough to impersonate
them however I like so if you only have
a very simple site that you require
people to log in to try and be very
careful with what you do with their
passwords because again if if users are
impersonating people on your site you
may not care but your users don't know
security and they're doing terrible
things like some of you may also have
just gotten very scared when I told that
as I did when I was first told these
types of things I didn't know any better
I figured well I'll have certain types
of passwords and that'll keep me safe
but again it's important to as you're do
using these key derivation function so
you want to make them as strong as you
possibly can as many iterations as you
can stand because what that means is is
if you if you're using the the password
functions in PHP and you go through a
large number of iterations every time I
want to try and attack your passwords I
have to do a large number of iterations
every single time for each attempt a
brute-force so how many people here
remember Ashley Madison the talk about
Ashley Madison all right all right
that's a little or popular so Ashley
Madison was a website for non-marital
Affairs most of the individuals most of
the men on this site were marital they
were also because of the the way the
site work they tended to be unusually
important a large number of military
government and high-level c-class
executives information was found on this
site and it used B was PHP and it used
the password function which meant it was
very secure so the people attacking it
after they were able to
there's there's this thing called the
top 100 passwords it's a list that
people keep updated from things they've
been able to attack they said I'll try
the first 100 which gives you anywhere
from ten to thirty percent of the
password base and then they just stopped
because it's just too expensive to try
and just brute-force all the other
passwords one character at a time until
they found a back door because they had
left in a separate hash non key
derivation that was built using the
username and the unencrypted password
and the unn unn hashed password which
was just a sha-1 and so using that using
the known username and then known the
civil in there they were able to just
generate everybody's passwords so always
important Keter Batian because attackers
will just walk away more often than not
because they know that by the time they
are able to crack it the users will
change most users will change their
passwords
that's why cuter evasion isn't important
so getting good cryptography we have a
kind of basic understanding of how
cryptography works the key to your own
implications will be using good
cryptography and is cryptography has
been used for centuries with varying
levels of success
many of us have likely used bad
cryptography at some point and if you're
as old as I am
it may have often been good cryptography
when you started using it right that's
like using an md5 or a sha for password
12 years ago using a salted sha-1 for a
password was considered the best
password security available and it was
just fine but today I can crack that on
my phone so as technology increases so
does the the need to make use better
cryptography but it's important I think
for you to understand what makes good
cryptography because what is good
cryptography changes throughout the
years it will change and change and
change and change PFS PHP 7 2 is taking
us to a new level of cryptography with
live sodium
but it's important to understand why
it's important and what makes it good so
good cryptography makes it obscures data
in such a way that it's difficult and
costly to duplicate a reverse right just
we talked about with the key derivation
it's making it very expensive to try and
get someone's password when you're using
algorithms you want them to be very
costly and difficult because it's going
to make it harder and there's a very
good reason for that and we'll talk
about kind of how this works and why
it's important into two different
sections entropy and computational cost
and well if you don't what entropy means
we'll get to that as well they're
independent as well as interdependent so
things that can be can have good entropy
have nothing to do with the computation
but together they create good
cryptography so when attacking it
there's two ways that you can attack
cryptography one is pattern analysis the
other one is brute force and pattern
analysis is you often hear it referred
to as crypt analysis that's taking some
information you know about the subject a
raw subject and seeing if you can
determine patterns and the other one is
just trying it again is this it no is
this it no this it no that's brute force
so brute force is much like smacking a
rock with a hammer if you hit a rock
with a hammer long enough the rock will
break depending on the size of the
hammer is how long it will take all
right because you can sit there with a
very small hammer or just keep it in the
rock if you've seen very small streams
cut through rock over centuries right
it's possible it's just difficult and
costly in cryptography it's just trying
it over and over again all right is this
it is this it is this it try the
combination but based on Moore's law the
Hammers get more powerful
every year more processing power more
processing power and with networks never
computing you can get multiple devices
working on the problem the same time and
with cloud platforms you don't even have
to purchase it right you can just rent
the processing power from the cloud or
you can build new hammers so these are
Asics
this is application specific integrated
circuits and all these things do if you
know anything about cryptocurrency these
are miners and all that they are
programmed to do is generate hashes they
are extremely fast at generating hashes
there's also chips that are very good at
math so this is a an NVIDIA GeForce chip
and this is a GPU GPUs are very good at
making Mac mathematic computations so if
you're going to try and break some
encryption this is fantastic they also
do really well at generating hashes and
we won't even get into the quantum
problem all right there are some
algorithms that are available in PHP
that are considered quantum secure and
it's not because they can beat quantum
computers it's just that the algorithms
were made in with a type of complexity
that makes it difficult for the current
quantum computers to do but nobody is
going to be using quantum computers to
break your encryption today it will be
the quantum computers of tomorrow so
we'll see where that goes but there are
ways to fight all that power and
algorithm complexity is one of the top
kid things they're harder math requires
more computation so the difference
between algorithms before and algorithms
today is that the new algorithms are
more computationally complex it requires
more CPU to generate the encrypted value
or decrypt
the the encrypted value back to plain
text and history is littered with
algorithms that were too easy to
brute-force M crypt is no longer in PHP
that explains everything right it had
algorithms that were so old and so
outdated and the fact that the library
itself was it was taken away because it
was too old but most of the algorithms
that were available weren't even
considered safe right so when I started
using PHP a lot
ten years ago Triple DES was considered
safe it's now considered completely
terrible don't use it
AES is the new standard but now that's
changing as well with loop so do so it's
constantly evolving to create more
complex algorithms large keys are also
very helpful depending on your algorithm
specifically very large prime numbers in
asymmetric encryption algorithms so your
everyone here have to update their
website to something larger than a 1k
key a year and a half ago for google
nobody post website and Google said you
need to change this so we're gonna lower
your rankings okay so Google lead was
about a year and a half ago said if you
don't have a like I think it was three
years ago they said if your site isn't
secured by SSL you're gonna drop in the
rankings and everybody said oh no SSL
and let's encrypt was born right
the easy way to the easy and free way to
do SSL shortly after that they said 1k
keys are not enough because there are a
lot of sites with 1k keys out there so
two key keys are required and that's
what we mean by large keys what that
what oh I thought what a 2k key is is
that's a 20 mm 48 byte integer so very
large integer and it's a it's not just
an integer it's a prime number so just
finding a prime number that size is very
difficult doing math on it's even more
complicated which makes it difficult to
brute-force if you're using symmetric
encryption your larger key means there
as they try and brute-force it's more
combinations that you have to try which
makes it again more difficult so the
larger the key size the more secure
system resources requiring large amounts
of sis immune resources can prevent the
ability to use the things that you're
not expecting to use something like an
ASIC or GPU they're very good at doing
little things very small computations
but if you require that they use two
threads they can't do that or if you
require that they use a hundred and
hundred Meg's of RAM they can't do that
either or even a Meg of RAM on most of
them so you can increase the complexity
by adding in the requirement for using
memory or using a number of threads
which is what the new password stuff
does for for Lib sodium and the argon to
I implementation iteration so in
iteration you're just doing it more
times all right so whether it's more
substitution inside of your encryption
algorithm that's part of making them
more difficult is that they do more
substitution rounds they do more
mathematic rounds your binary
mathematics makes it more complicated
and makes it more expensive to do and
then password hashing is the big one
right where you just do it again and
again and again and again and again
again as many times as you can bear and
that will that will do that so the other
tool for cracking is crypt analysis and
graph analysis and I show the the puzzle
up here because in World War two these
are the people they would find to break
codes they would find people who are
really good at crossword puzzles because
crossword puzzles you have a question
you might have two or three of the
letters and you have to come up with a
word that would match so you'd have to
have the subject matter and a couple
hints and they could find the words
which is basically what Krypton
this is today we use machine learning
alright we don't need people we have
machines so mixing the knowledge and
identifying the patterns to fill in the
blanks it's been used for years but
today brute force is usually easier but
if you could reduce the cost of brute
force you're going against what you're
trying to create right you're trying to
make it more expensive and more
difficult if you can reduce the amount
of effort you have to spend in brute
force by understanding what certain
pieces are most likely to be then you're
reducing that cost for brute force so
entropy we talked about this a little
bit earlier cryptanalysis has fought
with entropy removing order and creating
the appearance of randomness right in
computers there is actually no such
thing as random but we can try and make
the parents of randomness as individuals
we cannot do random because we have our
own biases herbs are our bias and we
have we were more likely to come up with
the same if you said come up with a
random string in your head if you wrote
them all down you would come up without
eventually if there's a large enough
list you would see that a certain number
of values would come out more often than
others because it wouldn't be random
because your head doesn't work that way
and computers are programmed to do the
same thing the same way every single
time if a computer does something random
you have a problem we call those bugs
all right so trying to get computers to
you random can be difficult and
real-world data has very predictable
patterns which is why entropy is such a
big deal in computing so if you take for
example an HTTP message so this is a
very standard HTTP message where you
make a request to get information and
it's going to give you back data this is
the response right so I'm asking for
account information and it's returning
me account information so JSON responses
looked very similar I can very easily
guess just by looking at someone's API
documentation what these pieces will be
I know that I'm going to be getting a
200 response I know that content types
could be application JSON a very quick
query will tell me what the server name
and version is and I know what the
fields are going to be all that is going
to always be the same on every response
unless they change the server version or
they change their API so I can very
quickly predict most of the data in this
response other pieces are highly
predictable if I know when I'm making
the request I will know what the
response date is going to be right
for one second I will know and then the
next second I will always know I also
know so I have a second to try and do
terrible things before this is not valid
but honestly how many people validate
the response times all right so it
doesn't necessarily matter
I just hasn't it just has to be a time
if you're even looking at that header at
all other data also has predictability
so dates of birth there are people that
were born more likely on particular
years than other years there are people
that are if you'll notice birthdays tend
to fall on particular months as opposed
to other months less predictable now
based on the fact that everybody lives
in for all many people live in climate
controlled environments people that
would be in this type of database
probably our names there are a limited
number of names and you can definitely
determine that a certain number of names
are much more popular based on the
language and locale than other names so
there's predictability there and then
some sort of identifier most countries
are going to their country identify are
becoming random values some of them used
to just be counters so based on the date
I had no arrange the date of your birth
I know the range of your ID number your
country ID number again that's changing
credential data credential data is also
highly predictable most services use
email for the username so if I know your
email address which most people don't
think is being terribly private it
passed around on cards it's on every
single it's on your Twitter account it's
everywhere right
if I'm if you use that as a username
then I have half of what I need already
to attack you I have half the credential
passwords also have a high
predictability use so 68% of people
reuse their passwords so that means that
I will use a single password on more
than one site
I think that's low but in 2015 that was
the value right and the top 25 passwords
so when you get all the passwords on
these nefarious dark websites these
paste bin sites that you can go you
yourself can you go find everybody's
passwords on paste bins today the top 25
of those constituted over 50% of the
passwords so if I get a password
database and I just to try and that the
top 25 passwords so I taught each one of
these items I try 25 times I am 50%
likely to get it I'll be able to hit the
password in 25 tries that's problematic
nearly 17% of users safeguard their
accounts with 1 2 3 4 5 6
very scary but most people hate
passwords
I hate passwords I have pledged my life
to getting rid of passwords for the last
three years but they're there and people
hate them and they just want something
they can remember so they will do the
minimum necessary to get past the
password policy most users will change
will choose passwords based on the ease
of recall right rather than entropy so
because of that the reuse the
predictability it creates a serious
problem as people who are trying to
secure the web and protect people from
themselves we have to create you know
the lack of uniformity across our data
set so if you take a look at this data
set if you're if you're like me and
notice patterns very quickly you will
see things that are matching these are
three users with the same password right
so as that said 15% of your users will
have the same password what two three
four five six right so what you're
trying to do is you don't want them to
be able to single it out because without
having to run a single query against or
a single attack attempt if I can see in
the data that three out of five of these
the same I'm going to guess that's one
two three four five six just by knowing
passwords or that's the same user with
multiple usernames but you have you will
have commonalities across the data set
right in your password database 25
percent of the people will be one two
three four five six so all I have to do
is go through there and find it so good
cryptography uses random salts to add
entropy to hashes so you add the salt to
the password and now they're all
different and that's why you put salts
on two passwords so that you cannot use
the known tendencies for passwords
against your database if you're ever
wondering
but nearly every type of data has
recognizable patterns so English as a
language has patterns spaces can be
determined very predictably most
languages spaces can be data very
predictive a single letter words have a
very limited number of characters two
letter words are very predictable as
well three letter words and then the
most common letter in all the words if
you don't add some randomness to that
it'll be very easy to predict what they
are so this is actually using really
good encryption without using entropy so
you can see that this is encrypted
birthdates
or just dates right so the first two are
the same we don't want that but even if
they weren't the same they're all very
similar most of the data in here is the
same so this is encryption using an auth
tag which is a hash this is very modern
encryption so modern encryption doesn't
help you without adding entropy the only
difference in these things is one letter
or two letters to different segments but
in the first segment there's only two
options in the second segment there are
also only two options
so this is very very recognizable
patterns so using randomness in a random
initialization vector and encrypted data
they're all different that's why it's
important to have randomness and
encryption as well as you want to make
sure that that same data isn't the same
so random salts and IVs are necessary
necessary necessary unfortunately it's
easy to get so C spring
cryptographically secure pseudo-random
number generation big word just use
random bytes write PHP random bytes
that's all you need it does all that for
you if the big word you don't need to
remember if you need to generate an IV
if you need to generate assault random
bytes it's going to do all this stuff to
make sure that it actually is random
it's not predictable good because if you
don't
people can based on the time that you
execute it have a fairly high likelihood
of figuring out what that value is when
you generate it so you want to make sure
you're doing it properly
all right I've just thrown a lot of data
at you and it's been like 40 minutes so
what I can tell you is that today you
can do very very simple things use the
password extension PHP has the best
password option on the planet I have
worked in a lot of languages and there
is nothing better it's very simple to
use you can very quickly determine if it
needs to be rehashed based on new
algorithm you can upgrade the algorithms
in place it has very same defaults just
use it because when you need new hash a
new hashing algorithm you can very
quickly just change a value from
password default to pass one argonne to
i and you now have argon to I and it you
can rehash in place so just use it just
use it just use it if you're using a
framework make sure they're just using
it because it makes your life easier
down the road I promise you live sodium
brand-new and seven to documentation is
terrible I'm trying to work on that
there is no documentation all right
the person who wrote it has a patch for
it I'm trying to work to help him get
that patch into the PHP Doc's but we'll
see how that goes
but we are working on it and it actually
simplifies encryption if you've done
little corruption before when you want
when you need a key what size key do you
need I don't know when I look at the
docs right it's very complicated very
difficult it just gives you constant to
do that it's very easy to generate the
nonce go through all these things and
very quickly do it right you don't have
to guess anything you don't have to know
anything right you just call the
function pass it there text the key and
the nonce
and it encrypts it you don't have to
guess algorithm you don't need to know
strength you'll need to know iterations
it's just going to do it it's supposed
to be simple the only thing it's not
simple is the length and the names of
the functions and the constants because
they are really really really long I do
a talk just on that and sometimes just
the function takes up the entire length
of the screen it's complicated
but it's easy okay Lib sodium is easy
the password function is easy and at
least now you know why you should use
them because it's important
introductory books so the codebook is a
really good story telling book about how
cryptography worked over time and it
gave me a lot of insight into why is
this this way why is this that way if
you're interested it's a really good
book if you want to get deep into crypto
cryptography engineering talks about the
if you're a math geek talks about math
algorithms and explains the math behind
it so if you're someone like me who
better understands physics when you can
do the math this is a good book for you
if you're not one of those people you
can just skip the math and I'll still
explain it pretty well and then serious
cryptography is a new book that I'm
reading that's actually pretty good it
does a really good with randomness there
are websites so the password manual it
actually talks about it fairly well if
you want to use sodium the Pecola
documentation is identical to the PHP
the PHP extension and you can also start
using lip sodium today using the petal
installation
there's also open ssl and sea spring the
information is there as well and then a
lot of things I learned about
cryptography I learned from Wikipedia
because it really has really good
information on how does RSA work how do
we live house elliptical curve work
what's an EDD to 5:09 curve those types
of things so check that out if you want
to get really really into it and then we
have like 30 seconds for questions
questions okay if you have other
questions which you probably do but your
force for time I'm going to be here all
week so please just come see me and fly
me down I love talking about this stuff
check out the books I'll put the slides
up somewhere so you can go through those
again and thank you for coming
[Applause]